i decided to conduct a special military  operation  its goal is the protection of the people  who for eight years suffered from abuse  and genocide from the kiev regime  we urge you to lay down arms immediately  and go home  i will explain  all servicemen of the ukrainian army who  comply with this requirement can freely  leave the area of military action and  return to their families  whoever would try to stop us and further  create threats to our country to our  people should know that russia's  response will be immediate and lead you  to such consequences that you have never  faced in your history  we are ready for any outcome